in case you haven't heard the good news
both Microsoft edge and WebKit Safari
are now supporting service workers in
their preview releases this is a huge
leap forward and sets up 2018 to be the
year of progressive web apps with that
being said what I want to show you today
is how to handle touch events that only
happen on mobile devices then use
angular to create animations in response
to these events as you can see here we
run a different animation on this
material card every time the user swipes
in a different direction if you're new
here make sure to subscribe and I
recommend that you follow along with the
source code at angular firebase comm and
while you're at it
I also recommend checking out Paul
Holidays YouTube channel and all the
awesome angular content he's creating
over there I'm going to kick this
episode off by building a brand new
angular app then we have a couple of
dependencies to add the first one being
hammer J S which is used to add support
for mobile touch events to your
progressive web app including rotate
pinch press pan tap and swipe then you
can install it in your app by running
NPM install hammer J s Flags save then
once installed we're going to go into
the main TS file and make sure to import
hammer J s there that'll make the events
globally available throughout your app
in this demo I'm using angular material
but that part is completely optional you
can follow the install instructions on
the official repo the important part is
that you install angular animations
which is included in the angular mono
repo so you can just install it with NPM
and then make sure to include it inside
of your app module so you should have
browser animations module inside of the
imports array we're going to be modeling
our animations after the animate CSS
library which is one of the most popular
libraries on github the library itself
is just a collection of CSS keyframe
animations so all we have to do is port
those over to angular so we can use it
with angular's browser animations module
we don't actually need to install this
package in our angular project instead
we're just going to copy and paste the
CSS keyframes over to the angular
animations keyframes the end result is
that we'll be able to trigger animations
natively in angular this will give us
fine-grained control over the animation
lifecycle making it much easier to
manage the animations state as our app
grows more complex this can be extremely
valuable if you're building something
like swipeable tinder cards or if you
just want to
optimize the animations for your mobile
users now that we have all of our
dependencies in place let's go ahead and
create a new component called hammer
card the first thing we'll do is set up
the component type script so we're going
to import the necessary tools from
angular animations then I'm going to
import a keyframes file that has not yet
been created but we're going to do that
in the next step then inside the
component decorator we'll go ahead and
create an animations array and this is
where we define each of the animations
as well as the animation trigger so the
trigger is called card animator and
every time that trigger changes it will
transition to a different state so to
define a transition we use the wild card
which means any state that transitions
to wobble will animate in 1000
milliseconds then we'll tell it to
animate with the wobble keyframes that
we're going to define in that key frames
file we're going to follow the same
exact steps for each of our animations I
have 6 in total in this demo so we can
just add those line by line inside of
this animation trigger after that we can
go into the component and we'll define a
variable to hold the animation state to
trigger an animation all we have to do
is define the animation state as a
string that matches one of the
animations that we defined above to do
that I'll create a method called start
animation that takes a state as an
argument then I'm wrapping it in an if
statement so we don't have two
animations trying to run at the same
time and after each animation completes
we want to reset the animation state
back to an empty string so I'll go ahead
and create another method to handle that
the next step is to define the keyframes
that we referenced earlier so create a
new file called keyframes TS and you can
put this file wherever you want and it
can be shared throughout your
application first we'll import keyframes
in style from angular animations and
then I'm going to pull up animate CSS
side-by-side so you can see how this is
done all we're doing in this file is
exporting variables that define the
keyframes that we're going to use in the
animation each element in the array is a
style that represents a relative point
in time in the CSS keyframes to the
right the relative point in time is the
percentage but in angular it's
represented by the offset property
in this object the basic process is that
we convert that percentage to a decimal
and add it to the offset property and
then we're also going to copy and paste
over the CSS styles from each keyframe
it's a somewhat tedious process and
eventually angular is going to have its
own CSS parser but for now this is the
best way to go about it to keep this
brief I'm only going to show you this
first animation here but you can find
all of the animations in the github
project for this video if we look a
little closer at the completed keyframes
you can see we start at point two and
then we ended an offset of point eight
keyframes seem to be ordered ascending
based on their offset and the last
keyframe should be no greater than one
if you remember earlier we set our
transition to be 1000 milliseconds so
it's going to cycle through these
keyframes based on that duration of time
with the keyframes in place let's jump
over to the component HTML and start
putting this together so we start with
the material card then we define the
animation trigger by calling at Card
animator with the animation state then
angular calls a done event when the
animation is finished so when it's
finished we're going to reset the
animation state back to an empty string
now we have a whole bunch of hammer j/s
gesture touch events that we can start
playing with first we'll listen to the
swipe left event when the user swipes
left we'll call the start animation
function and pass it the slide out left
animation for swipe right we'll use the
zoom out right animation then we'll also
add swipe up and swipe down but these
ones are going to need some additional
configuration which we'll get to in the
next step then we can go ahead and add
the angular logo and some default text
to our card then we'll set up a couple
material buttons to trigger animations
on a button click or tap with hammer J
ass a tap is similar to a click but
optimized for mobile devices and can
provide some additional metadata for pre
ding custom events at this point you can
open up chrome dev tools and run the
mobile application emulator and you
should see all the animations running
like you would expect so that's pretty
cool but I still want to show you how
you can create your own custom events as
well as customize the behavior of hammer
J s the swipe up and swipe down events
are disabled by default but if we want
to enable them we can import hammer J s
into our app
and then angular has a hammer gesture
config built into platform browser you
create your own hammer config class and
then you give it an overrides object
which gives you access to the full
hammer jsapi you can check out all the
options in the hammer Docs but for now
we just need to set the swipe event to
Direction all then to use this config we
need to go down to providers and tell
angular to use our custom class that'll
get the swipe up and swipe down events
working but I want to take this one step
further and create my own custom events
this is a perfect use case for an
angular directive which I'm going to
call hammer time then to create custom
events and angular you're going to need
host listener output and event emitter
first we'll use the output decorator on
a property called double tap which is
equal to a new event emitter and double
taps going to happen whenever the user
taps twice on an object and then we'll
do the same thing for triple tap which
is the same exact thing but when a user
taps three times to create these custom
events will first listen to the main tap
event coming from hammer Jas and hammer
gives us the tap count for each event so
we can just wrap that in an if statement
and if the tap count equals two then we
know that the user has double tap then
inside the if block will call double tap
omit this event now the process is
exactly the same for triple tap just
looking for the tap count to equal three
now our director is ready to put to use
so we'll go back to our component HTML
and add the directive to whichever
button we want to listen to these custom
events so you can see here we add
another button with the hammer time
directive and then we can listen to the
double tap event in parentheses then we
can run the same start animation
function and pass whichever animation we
want to use there if we go back to our
app and tap the button once you can see
nothing happens but if we double tap
than it does the jello animation that's
just barely scratching the surface of
angular animations and hammer j/s
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to take your
app to the next level consider becoming
a pro subscriber at angular firebase
comm you'll get access to a support
network designed to help you get your
app built and shipped into production as
well as a free copy my book and access
to exclusive content every week thanks
for watching and I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]